vendôme ville d'art et d'histoire
sous ce label on peut imaginer une jolie
fille l'ancien bâti dès le douzième
siècle mais de grands changements
interviennent sur ce paysage urbain
notamment après guerre devant l'essor
démographique la ville se développe en
1956 un grand projet d'habitat collectif
voit le jour sur 83 hectares le quartier
des rottes aînés nous retrouvons valérie
animatrice du patrimoine pour une
première visite virtuelle de ce nouveau
quartier au centre d'interprétation du
paysage de vendôme le quartier va être
en fait un quartier essentiellement au
tout début
un quartier d'habitat collectif comme on
peut le voir sur sur certaines images
ici on voit en fait quelques immeubles
qui sont associés également à des
petites maisons et dans ce quartier là à
partir du des années 60 on va commencer
à se dire il faut quelques équipements à
cette période 1500 logements collectifs
et 500 maisons individuelles abritent un
tiers de la population vendômoise pour
la plupart salariés dans les industries
nouvellement implantés les besoins des
familles nécessite magasin mairie école
église qui seront créés entre 1956 et
1980 c'est que deschamps oui voilà alors
tous derrière chez moi c'était que des
choses les mêmes les bâtiments qu'il y a
à gauche vous l'envoyer par là n'étaient
pas là pas construire ces constats la
presse
au kenya le bureau de tabac où il y
avait calmé même pas la moitié
et puis après il y avait une droguerie
qu'ils accordent à la droguerie à la
fermer ils ont racheté pour ce faire un
grand magasin c'est vrai que c'est
magnifique change mais autrement il y
avait juste ginette s'est installé au
rot en 1967
ces nouveaux logements représentait
alors le confort moderne
j'étais dans un meublé et qu'il n'y
avait pas de sanitaires après l'accord
bâle
alors avant d'arriver ici vous savez
vous
je veux dire vous avez la douche vous
avez l'eau chaude vous avez tout de tout
le confort c'est dans le nouvel
appartement c'était quand même beaucoup
mieux
c'est surtout ça qui nous a quand même
fait venir s'il y avait quand même le
centre commercial
il y avait tout un poissonnerie
charcuterie boules de boucher droguerie
tabac et c'est vraiment il y avait en
étudiant qu'on aime câlins avec les
infrastructures publiques et les
commerces
une vraie vie de quartier s'installe les
rots accueil rapidement plusieurs
populations des ruraux devenu ouvrier
des pieds noirs rapatriés d'algérie des
africains du nord une importante
communauté turque et une population plus
aisée
attirés par les pavillons individuels
dernière tranche de construction des
rottes sylvain directeur du centre
culturel connaît bien le quartier
il ya une cohésion du quartier comme
dans d'autres quartiers ici qui se
reconnaît quelles que soient les
populations que la cette forme d'unité
du quartier donc le fait d'appartenir au
quartier des proches dans une même
enceinte fait que ça rapproche
mais on le voit aussi dans tout ce qu'on
a pu voir on s'aperçoit que des fois la
proximité très proche et pas toujours
facile à vivre
alors c'est pas forcément toujours des
grands problèmes mais c'est des petites
questions de voilà de connaissance de
l'autre d'acceptation de l'autre de
différences culturelles de différences
de fonctionnement
l'après guerre et la création urgente de
nombreux logements ont donné vie à une
architecture radical pragmatique ou le
béton prédomine le confort moderne va de
pair avec des appartements plus ou moins
sonore et une forte proximité
pourtant les rots comme d'autres
quartiers hlm fourmis d'une vie
collective riche due à une mixité
sociale
ce modèle fonctionnera jusque dans les
années soixante dix ans de crise
économique où la mixité tend à
disparaître et la ghettoïsation grandir
aujourd'hui en france avec plus de 10
millions de personnes vivent en hlm une
question se pose comment dans ces grands
ensembles parvenir à créer un paysage
social et culturel épanouissant